black women in this country have fought
for equal pay and equal access to loans
for generations
so they can start their own businesses
and buy homes but new data out today
from goldman sachs shows they are still
two times more likely to live in poverty
and their average hourly wages are 34
less than white men they're also less
likely to own their own companies
we met one business owner her name is
jessica johnson cope who is trying to
change that
her company which has been in her family
for generations provides professional
security to businesses across the new
york metropolitan area
here's her story in her own words
my name is jessica johnson cope i am the
president
and ceo of johnson security bureau the
oldest black owned security firm
in new york state
johnson security bureau is a third
generation family owned and operated
security services firm based in the
bronx new york
founded by my grandparents dorothy and
wilbert johnson they started the
business in their house in 1962
to create a company where they could
provide jobs for people in the community
you may not see a lot of women-owned
firms in our neighborhood
you may not see a lot of big businesses
coming here
but when they see johnson security
bureau it gives them a sense of
hope that there is someone who looks
like them
who's achieved some level of success
the goldman sachs 10 000 small
businesses program was launched in 2009
as an answer to the financial crash of
2008
and i got the chance to interview with
one of the members of the executive team
at goldman sachs
she said what if you had resources what
if someone showed you
how you could better run your business
what if you could use
other people's money and in that way put
more people to work
and have a greater impact on your
community and we've had sensational
results
i mean we've gone from 16 employees to
over 160
our revenues have increased
significantly if you
have the desire and you have the right
tools
you can find success whatever that means
to you
16 employees to 160 that's impressive
growth goldman sachs
is announcing a new 10 billion dollar
plan to invest in jobs
health care and housing for black women
chairman and ceo david solomon joins us
with the head of the firm's
urban investment group margaret anadu
this is their first tv interview about
the announcement good morning to you
both and i'm very glad it's warm enough
in new york that you're both outside on
the roof great to see you good
well we're we're really happy to be with
you this morning and it's
it is definitely almost warm enough to
be out on the roof
i'm probably just a little bit
underdressed all right david let's
let's get you going and warm you up
first how will goldman sachs invest that
10
million billion dollars to help black
women
well we're very very excited about this
program and we've been working for quite
some time
to think about a way that we can have a
lasting economic impact
the earnings gaps and also the wealth
gaps that exist for black women
who are so important in the community
based on all they're doing are very very
significant and so we've really been
working
toward putting together a longer term
plan to disperse this capital in ways
that can really drive
broader economic participation narrow
gaps
and really help drive more participation
in the economy i'd like margaret to talk
a little bit about some of the things
that we're thinking specifically about
to drive those results
over time go ahead margaret yeah
so as we think about the 10 billion
dollars and and the impact that we can
have here you know you heard from
from jessica johnson just what it means
to have that access to capital
but we want to do something much broader
here and that's why we want to invest in
health care
education housing child care because
stepping back right these are the
foundational elements in a black woman's
life that really drive economic
prosperity
and we think when we can start to narrow
some of those opportunity gaps
we unlock her potential we lift her up
and that's not just important for those
black women
but also we're going to see the impact
on their families on our communities
and we feel pretty strongly we're going
to drive progress overall margaret in
2018
you were the youngest black woman to be
named a partner at goldman sachs
what needs to be done to get more black
women in leadership positions
you know i think even an initiative like
this and what we're building right this
is about the
infrastructure that allows more black
women to be at the table
and so when we can get more black women
that college degree when we can help
with the upskilling when we can help
black women
really advance in their careers you're
going to see more you know black women
at the table and quite frankly i think
to sort of drive the type of progress
in initiatives like this that we need to
see well seeing you standing there side
by side with david solomon i think sends
a very important message margaret i want
to go back
to you david because i love the the the
question that jessica
posed in the piece what would you do if
you had the resources that
she was asked that by goldman sachs so
why is this important to you i want you
to take us behind the scenes
about your thinking on this and it's
more than just making opportunities for
black women in business
absolutely gail it's much more than that
and i think the the firm has learned a
lot over the last five years
as we have over the last 15 years as
we've made investments
in other programs i know that you're
familiar with like our ten thousand
women program
and our ten thousand small business
program that jessica is highlighting
what we've learned is that if we take
our research
and we really dig deep to try to
understand where there are problems or
gaps in our society
and then we take our resources our
capital our network
our ability to give people advice and
help them gain access to capital
we can create a very positive impact
over time we can help lift people up we
can help them participate and by the way
it's great for those people
but more importantly for our society it
helps us all economically
if we can close the wage gap for black
women in this country we can create
1.7 million more jobs and we can
increase
economic gdp output by about 450 billion
dollars
so we all benefit from broader
participation and that's why
the research that we're putting out this
morning black womenomics
helps us understand where we can all
make investments to help drive our
society forward
david the house is expected to uh to
pass today to vote today on the 1.9
trillion dollar relief package the covet
relief package
what else needs to be done i mean do you
think it's enough to begin with and what
else do you think needs to be done to
get the economy going again
well i think the most important thing i
think the economy is starting to do
better as we've all seen
as we are making progress on the
pandemic the most important gaining item
for us to get more economic recovery is
to continue to advance on the vaccine
and for us to get to a place where
people feel healthy
safe and secure that they can operate
out in the world in a way that's normal
and they can participate so the biggest
thing right now is to continue to get
vaccines distributed continue to get the
uptake
so that we can move forward and get past
this horrible health crisis
which has really just amplified some of
these inequalities
that we see in our society david
sullivan solomon
margaret anadu thank you both for being
with us this morning
we appreciate it